And now it's the old scout master.
I'd like to begin every podcast with something a little light-hearted, but this week I'm taking
a little bit of a different direction.
A number of you got in touch with me this week and asked what I had to say about a national
news story that reported on a trio of scout leaders who toppled a balanced rock called
a hoodoo at Utah's Goblin Valley State Park.
Now they came to national attention because they recorded their actions at the
park on a video and they posted that video to YouTube.
The authorities saw it and they are investigating the incident for possible
felony vandalism charges against these scouters.
Now, personally, I find the actions of these scouters distressing, but I'm going to
leave it to others to pass judgment on them.
They asserted that they were concerned that the rock was unstable and it could
have injured somebody.
Both the local authorities and the BSA are looking into the matter and they'll
pass judgment.
I'm taking the time to mention this because I think that there's a bit of an allegory
here that we may find useful in thinking about our role as scouters.
So some of us scouting can be a little bit of an alien landscape.
Now, I've never been to Utah and I've never visited Goblin Valley State Park
but I've looked at some pictures of it and for somebody who grew up where I
did, in the forests of the Mid-Atlantic, that's kind of an alien landscape and
there's some hoodoos in scouting that look kind of unstable and unlikely as
that balanced rock.
Engaging youth in positions of real responsibility and the intricacies
of the patrol system are good examples.
Some aspects of scouting form a landscape that looks as alien to us
as that fascinating landscape of the Goblin State Park, and we might even
be able to talk ourselves into toppling some of those carefully balanced
aspects of the program because they don't seem to make sense.
We want to rationalize the landscape and make it safer and more familiar
to our expectations.
So when this temptation arises we ought to do what those
scouting probably should have done.
We ought to step back and think before we make any changes.
We ought to strive to appreciate the forces at work that formed
this landscape of scouting rather than trying to modify it to suit
our own tastes and our own concerns.
And lastly, I'll add, our scouts are going to disappoint us every
once in a while and sometimes things are going to go wrong and
sometimes it takes a little bit of effort to dig down and to find
something positive in it,
And that's why I wanted to discuss this quickly before we begin
the podcast today.
I think that one way of looking at this we might be able to
find a positive message in an otherwise pretty tragic
and difficult event.
You can let me know what you think about the matter and you'll
find out how to do that later on in the podcast.
In the meantime, this is podcast number 192..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag. this week.
Todd Archer wrote in to say thanks for the October Scout
Circle presentation on backpacking. in three weeks
We'll be taking our troop, which includes six new tenderfoot
scouts, on their first backpacking trip.
It said that the Lord works in mysterious ways,
His wonders to perform, and his timing and yours was impeccable.
Thanks again.
I plan on being around for next month's broadcast, as you
never can have too many resources.
Well, thanks, Todd.
I'm glad that we were well timed.
I can't necessarily claim divine inspiration in that.
Hey, I'll take what I can get right.
Bill Daniel wrote in about the Scout Circle and he said
thanks to Joe Dacaruso, Arlam Ward and yourself.
The October Scout Circle was great fun.
It reminded me of my dad's ham radio days of yours.
Scouters love to talk about scouting, don't they?
Yes, they do, Bill,
And I'm glad you enjoyed our October Scout Circle.
Our November Scout Circle happens on Sunday,
November 10th.
It's a live presentation that begins at 9 pm,
Eastern Daylight Time, and lasts for about an hour,
And what we try to do is have a guest to discuss
some aspect of scouting and answer your questions
about their area of expertise.
And coming up in our November Scout Circle
we're going to be talking about the transition from
weeblows to scouts.
So once again, Sunday November 10th at scoutscircleorg.
You can watch the broadcast there and you'll be able
to ask questions and things like that.
We have a great time doing it,
So join us, won't you?
I had this update from podcast 189..
One of the email questions that I addressed on that podcast
was about patrol choices.
The question that I got in part said this:
although I had my ideas of what a good configuration
of patrols would look like,
I kept my mouth shut, confident that, in my role as scout
master, I would sit back and observe.
I watched our new senior patrol leader do what many adults
might do:
They balanced the numbers and ranks and ages and separated
the boys who hadn't gotten along in the past when
they made up their new patrols.
In the end I saw a mishmash of ages and ranks and some
disappointed faces where friendships have been split up.
Hasn't it to intervene any further?
I just nodded my head and I kept my mouth shut.
If I step in and call time out on these new patrol
assignments, I would undermine and embarrass the new
senior patrol leader.
But if I don't step in, it looks like there may be
some unhappy scouts this year.
I'm looking for advice on what to do next
And my reply was, first of all, congratulations on keeping
your mouth shut.
That's, that's not easy for all of us to do. and let
things play out a little bit.
See if the patrol leaders council and the senior
patrol leader thinks that they might have to tweak
some of their new patrol assignments
If their choices cause them some difficulties down
the line. let's see if they can figure it out.
Keep an eye on the situation,
Be ready to ask some questions and offer some advice,
but give them the opportunity to see if they can
understand why their choices may have caused a couple
of problems.
And the scouter who inquired about this followed
my advice and I heard from him this week and he had
this to say: as it turns out, I didn't need to do
very much, as nature, a boar is a vacuum and a three
legged horse.
So scout troops aboard misconfigured patrols.
The scouts themselves worked it out after that
initial meeting where they rearranged the patrols.
There must have been a flurry of side conversations,
texts or emails among the scouts by our patrol
leaders council meeting. the following weekend,
The new senior patrol leader handed out a revised
list of patrols that made all the corrections
I would have advised him on, and then some. it really
does work.
Let the scouts tackle issues like this themselves
and they really can rise to the occasion.
I'm really happy to hear that everything worked
out as we had hoped. this is not always the case
and sometimes a little coaching or advising may be
necessary, but in this case, stepping back, observing
and, as the writer said, keeping your mouth shut
actually reaped some really big benefits.
So I'm glad to hear that things panned out the
way that they did.
Well, for the past couple of podcasts I've been
mentioning my new book, The Scouting Journey.
The almost kind of final draft is being proofread
and looked at and picked over right now,
So hopefully we'll be able to stay with our
publishing schedule that puts the new book in
your hands by mid-November.
I'll give you an update again next week, but
but things are moving right along and I think
we're going to be on schedule with it. in this
podcast, in Scout Master ship, in seven minutes
or less,
We're going to talk about how we judge the
requirement demonstrate scout spirit by living
the scout oath and the scout law in your everyday
life, and then we've got some email questions
to answer.
That's going to take up the remainder of the
podcast.
So let's get started.
Shall we scout Master ship in seven minutes
or less?
Well, there are some perennial questions in
scouting and I received an email this past week
that raised one of them yet again and it went
this way:
How do we judge the requirement demonstrate scout
spirit? tender fit through first class ranks
require a scout explains how he practices for
specific points of the scout law, but star life
and Eagle ranks repeat the requirement, without
any specification, of providing specific
examples. on the surface,
This is a self evaluation, but isn't scout spirit
best judged by how others see you?
We've had a couple of scouts who are disruptive
during troop meetings, who disappear on campouts
when work needs to be done and they kind of
just generally disregard the troop rules and
traditions that we have. when there's an
infraction of these rules and adult leader
does sit them down and tell them that this
kind of behavior is not acceptable,
It's not scout spirit. but this doesn't seem
to do very much good.
We don't have to wait long before there's a
new issue to talk about.
If I asked these scouts to self evaluate,
if I asked them if they demonstrated scout
spirit in their everyday lives, they would
probably reply with a straight face that
yes, they do, that they help put away dishes
at home, that they do their homework, that
they hold the door open for somebody.
But how can a scout who behaves in this
manner at a troop meeting or a camp out
be displaying scout spirit in his everyday
life? I mean, they can't make it through
an activity without causing trouble.
Our troop committee instituted a policy
that scout spirit can now only be signed
off if the scout master or the senior
patrol leader and another adult leader
agree. Needless to say, this has greatly
complicated the process, but it's also
put some real teeth into the requirement.
My question is: have we carried the
requirement beyond its original
intention. And if we have, how can I sign
off on scout spirit based on a scout's
self evaluation, When his fellow scouts
or other adult leaders, or even I, may
beg to differ with them? If the first
aim of scouting is to produce young
men of character, this seems to be
the most important requirement of all.
Yet there's precious little guidance
on who has the final say on it and
how to evaluate it, So any suggestions
you have would be appreciated.
Well, there's a lot to unpack here,
So bear with me. Let's be clear first
that there are really two types of
requirements that we evaluate in
scouting. There are objective
requirements and subjective requirements.
Objective standards for requirements
are basically just metrics.
You know, you go on a certain number
of camping trips, you swim a certain
distance, or something like that.
Subjective standards are, like the one
you mentioned about scout spirit,
ones that are based on individual
evaluations. One way to think
about this that might be helpful is
to imagine achieving scout spirit or
any other of these subjective
requirements was a literal foot race.
The finish line is an ideal standard
of behavior. Now, our scouts don't
all start the race at the starting
line. They started different places
along the track because they have
different home lives and characters
and habits and personalities that
place them ahead of or behind
their fellow scouts. Some begin
the race at the starting line.
You know they're the average guy
with no outstanding advantages or
deficits. Some begin 50 yards ahead
of the starting line because they
have greater advantages and skills
in a given area. Some are going to
begin 50 yards behind the starting
line because they have real problems
and deficits. So when the starter's
pistol sounds and the scouts are
off and running, the scout who started
ahead of their fellows is going to
finish the race very quickly
because they only had to cover a
short distance to that ideal
finish line. Amongst the kind of
average scouts who begin at the
starting line, maybe one covers
about 75% of the race, another
maybe 25%, and the scout who began
the race 50 yards behind the
starting line only gets up to the
starting line before the race is
over. Here's the question:
How much ground did each scout
cover? The scout that began
50 yards behind the starting
line and finished the race by
reaching the starting line may
have covered more ground than his
more talented, advantaged fellow
scout that reached the finish
line. See that scout that had
to start way back, may have
progressed more. and that's what
we're looking for. We're looking
for progress. When we're looking
at these subjective standards,
we're not necessarily recognizing
that a scout has achieved the
ideal at the finish line, but
that they have progressed
towards it. This aspect of
scouting is really difficult for
a lot of us, because it seems
very right in theory to require
that everyone reaches the same
finish line. but that's not
what we were after. We want all
of our scouts to progress.
That's why subjective standards
don't have a set objective
standard. They're based on
individual progress. Not
everyone thinks I have this
right. They think that we
should set rigorous standards
and only reward those scouts
who reach this ideal. Now I'd
agree with them if all of our
boys started at the same
point. but they don't. This is
why much of what boys achieve
in scouting is based on
individual progress rather
than a set ideal standard.
One of the greatest and most
satisfying things that you
can do as a scouter is look
for that progress and speak
words of honest encouragement.
when you see it Now, some of
our scouts move slowly,
unhaultingly. They take two
steps back for every three
steps they take forward. but at
least they're showing us
some progress. Your recognition
of that effort builds their
resolve. Your friendship
and counseling help them
build self-confidence, and
that always leads towards
progressively better behavior.
It may not lead to perfect
behavior, though, and you
may never break through, but
you will have done all that
you can do and made the
boys' life better for it.
Nine out of ten scouts are
going to meet the scout
spirit requirement on
self-evaluation without a
whole lot of argument. It's
that one out of ten. that's
going to take a lot more
effort on our part At a
Scoutmaster conference. we
work with them to set
goals for better behavior. We
talk to them, We don't talk
past them. We ask them
questions. We ask them if
they think that their level
of behavior meets that level
of scout spirit that they
would require of another
scout. If they say yes and
you disagree with them, well
tell them. but don't stop
there. Cooperate with them
and choose one specific
thing- Now nothing too
broad, but a very specific
kind of chore or task, for
instance, that they may have
shirked in the past. Find
something that presents
them with an opportunity
for immediate action right
there at that meeting, right
there on that camp out. When
they've completed that simple
goal, then you tell them
what a wonderful job they
did and engage them in
setting the next goal
for themselves. Build on
good behavior a little
at a time, with the idea
that you're working to
build their own internal
individual standard of
behavior. Engage their youth
leaders in supporting
these goals. Share what
you've discussed with the
scout and encourage them
to recognize these small
progressive steps. Now,
if you get this right-
and it takes a lot of work
and it takes a lot of
patience- you'll start
to see individual
scouts behavior improve.
It may be three steps
forward and two steps back,
but you're making progress,
and progress is the name
of the game. Now, if you
think that you can create
some objective standard
or institute a method
or policy through the troop
committee that handles
this question, I'm going
to tell you honestly
and in the spirit of friendship
that I think you're entirely
misdirected and mistaken.
Let's be honest here.
you and your fellow
scouts are likely to be
frustrated and even a little
angry with these scouts.
You know that's to be
expected, because it's
a perfectly normal human
reaction. What I think
you may be doing is
channeling this frustration
into creating a really
untenable policy
and trying to quote,
put teeth,
unquote into requirements.
Recognize this for what
it is, count to 10
and engage these scouts,
using the methods
I've described, to work
towards better behavior,
rather than dinging all
of the scouts with this
kind of encumbering
policy that you've created.
I'll say again,
the name of the game
is not perfection.
The name of the game
is progress,
and when we understand
that, as scouters,
we open doors
to fantastic opportunities
to help our scouts
grow and achieve
the main aim of scouting.
Go and campy. go and campy.
Find me a letter, send it
by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer
to one of your emails.
Hey, Jay Maniskalko
is with Bellbuckle, Tennessee,
and he wrote in to say
I thought I heard
on a past podcast
that totenship was not required,
but I can't seem to find
any information
or confirmation of that.
Can you give me a little insight,
along with what the policy is
for sheath knives?
Well, Jay,
if you read the rank requirements,
you're not going to find
any reference to totenship
as being a requirement
In second class.
requirement three
it says: demonstrate proper care,
sharpening and use
of the knife, saw and axe
and describe how they should be used.
Use those tools
to prepare tinder, kindling
and fuel for a cooking fire.
Now, totenship can certainly help with that.
but, as you can see,
absolutely earning the totenship card
is not required for rank advancement.
It is required
for wood carving merit badge,
but if it was absolutely
required for rank advancement
it would say so:
Is totenship a good way
to complete that requirement?
Well, of course it is.
It's a great idea,
I think. what happens, though, sometimes
is that scouts get a little overheated
with the whole totenship thing.
They demand that scouts
are actually carrying the card
and they clip corners off the card
for infractions of the rules
and they kind of turn themselves
into pocket knife police.
In my work
I work with tools all the time
and I have the scars to show
that I've learned to respect them.
If a scout waves a knife around
and does something stupid,
I mean I'm going to call them on it,
but in the spirit of an older brother,
not in the spirit of the knife police.
So it's not that I disagree
with the totenship card.
I just have an issue sometimes
with the spirit in which it's used.
As for sheath knives,
we turn to the guide to safe scouting
and we find this:
A sharp pocket knife
with a can opener on it
is an invaluable back country tool.
Keep it clean, sharp and handy.
Avoid large sheath knives.
They're heavy,
they're awkward to carry
and unnecessary for most camp chores,
except for cleaning a fish.
That's what the guide to safe scouting
says about knives.
It's pretty simple, isn't it?
So large sheath knives
should be avoided.
They aren't absolutely outlawed
in the guide to safe scouting.
Some council properties
and some troops
simplify this advice
by prohibiting sheath knives altogether,
but I note that
every patrol cook kit
usually has a whopping big kitchen knife
in it. right,
I mean, I have lots of sheath knives
and I use them from time to time,
but my pocket knife is more useful.
And I'll add that
common sense leads us to conclude
that sheath knives that were designed
principally for weapons
or as hunting knives
they're not going to be a whole lot
of use to scouts.
I don't have a problem with them,
I just don't think they're all that useful.
So, to kind of wrap it all together,
we want our scouts to be able to use knives.
They're an invaluable back country tool.
We want them to do it safely,
but we don't want to turn ourselves
into the knife police. right,
Theoretically, can a scout carry a sheath knife?
but we want to avoid sheath knives.
I think part of it's a safety matter,
but part of it's also
that they're really just not that useful.
Jay, I hope that helps you sort this out.
I also heard from Sean Keeney,
and Sean is an assistant cub master
with PAC 70 in Foxborough, Massachusetts.
He wrote in to say this:
We are going on a PAC overnight in November.
An older brother of one of our cubs
who just joined Boy Scouts
will be coming along.
I'd like him to have an active part of the trip
and be kind of like our den chief
for the weekend.
My question is this:
will his participation in the overnight
and activities on our camp out
count towards his advancement
towards Tenderfoot?
Thanks for the podcast.
I stumbled across it a few months ago
and I look forward to it each week.
Sean, thanks so much for listening.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast.
Thank you for being such a generous
assistant cub master
and working to include this scout.
make his experience a good one
when he goes camping with the PAC.
The first thing that we can do
to answer your question
is carefully read Tenderfoot
requirement number two,
And it says this:
Spend at least one night
on a patrol or troop camp out.
Sleep in a tent. you have helped pitch.
If we read that requirement carefully,
we see the words troop
and patrol. that's specified.
It's not a PAC or a den camp out.
So nights camping with the PAC
or den do not count
towards this requirement
unless the whole patrol is there
or unless the whole troop is there.
If we look at Tenderfoot requirement number three,
it says this: on the camp out,
assist in preparing and cooking
one of your patrol's meals.
Tell why it is important for each patrol member
to share and meal preparation
and clean up
and explain the importance of eating together.
Your patrol in that requirement
is not a den or a PAC
or a troop for that matter.
It's your patrol.
What you see in these requirements
is intended to get a scout
into the life of his patrol.
That's where all of scouting happens.
It's not simply going camping
or cooking a meal without any context.
it's doing these things with your patrol.
As for the other Tenderfoot requirements,
an older scout could certainly
learn and practice them
on a Cub Scout camping trip
If he has the time.
but who's supposed to be signing them off?
This is really the Scoutmasters prerogative.
If they give you permission to sign them off,
well, that's fine.
but most Scoutmasters will want
patrol leaders signing requirements
rather than adults.
Once again,
I think you're being very generous
and very helpful
and you're very right in theory
to offer as much opportunity
as you can for this scout.
but scouting is something more
than just checking things off a list
to look at the requirements carefully.
It's a lot about who we do things with
and how they are done.
that contextualizes the experience
we want Scouts to have
in fulfilling those requirements.
David wrote in with this question.
he said in my first year as Scoutmaster
I've been able to keep adults
out of the planning process
and let the Scouts make decisions.
At a recent meeting
it was pointed out by a parent
that a Veterans Day parade
we normally participate in
wasn't on their schedule.
Can I tell Scouts that they're in charge
without adult interference
and then turn around and tell them
they have to schedule this parade
because it's a traditional service
that the troop does in the community?
I think I would prefer that they
originate their own service ideas.
in all my efforts to give the Scouts
free reign and how they do things,
I am also running against
a kind of counterproductive message
on a part of some parents
that they have to become Eagle Scouts.
I'd appreciate any advice
you could give me on either of those matters.
Hey, David, you know, this kind of conundrum
comes up from time to time in any troop.
I don't think you have to direct here.
I think all you have to do
is sit down with the patrol leader's council
and explain the situation,
just like you did to me in this email.
You can sit down and say:
listen, I'm really invested
in your decision making,
in the way that you put your calendar together,
but it was brought to my attention
that we didn't include
the Veterans Day parade
in your plans
and I was wondering
what you thought about that.
Now, I'd imagine
they probably like to do the parade anyway.
maybe it was just an oversight
on their part.
maybe they really don't want to go
and do the parade.
You can take this opportunity
to have a conversation
about all the issues
that this involves,
and it will probably be
a great conversation too.
As far as parents
who have in their mind
that their boy
must become an Eagle Scout,
well, parents often
don't get what we're trying to do.
Remember that most of us
didn't get it at first either,
and given enough time,
most of them will get on board,
but some continue to pull
in the other direction.
If a Scout is on the fast track
to Eagle because his parents
are driving him.
I lend him all the support
and encouragement I can.
He has no control over
what his parents do,
and really neither do I.
We can try talking
and counseling
and doing what we can,
but remember
we're not the boy's parent.
we don't set the goals for him.
we can advise
and coach
and mentor
and see if we can help
set the situation straight,
but in no way
do we want to penalize a Scout
because his parents
happen to be a little pushy
or something like that.
David, I hope that helps.
I would love to have you again
in touch with me
and ask your questions
about scouting,
and I'll tell you how to do that
in just a minute.
Well, thanks for listening
to the 192nd edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
All the past editions
of the podcast
are available for download
or listening
on our podcast archive
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
While you're there,
you can join
over 2,500 email subscribers
and receive updates
to ScoutmasterCGcom
by email.
You can also
subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast
on iTunes
or access the podcast
on any mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details
about how to do that
at Stitchercom.
You can experience
the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
and help spread the word
by joining us
on the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right.
join over 4,200 folks
who follow us
at ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook.
Join our 400-plus
Twitter followers
at ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
Subscribe to watch
ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
and for admittance
to the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle,
Search for ScoutmasterCG
on Google+.
Now, if social media
just isn't your cup of tea,
well Bunky,
you can zoom into
the late 90s
and email me.
That's right.
I'd love to hear from you.
Email me, Clark Green,
with your comments
and questions
and wild ideas
and things like that.
at Clark,
at ScoutmasterCGcom,
It's C-L-A-R-K-E.
I want to let you know
that the ScoutmasterBlog
and the Scoutmaster Podcast,
they're not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
It's just me,
I've got a microphone
and I try to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit
of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
before we go
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pennel.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.
Thank you.